[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par rapport à ce qui existe sur le
marché donc les prothèses qu'on est en
train de développer sans beaucoup plus
intelligente parce qu on essaie
d'intégrer du machine learning dont
notre algorithme pour faciliter la
reconnaissance des signaux musculaires
aux utilisateurs elle est aussi donc
plus légères car ça l'impression 3d
personnalisable
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai toujours voulu faire un truc qui
changent positivement l'humanité et son
monde
j'ai commencé à rentrer des personnes
qui ont cette amputation ou seulement
aux cette différence de membres
supérieurs et inférieurs et j'ai
commencé à sympathiser avec eux ils sont
maintenant mes amis donc de croix qui et
mérite une vie meilleure
j'ai décidé de rester en tunisie est de
développer que ban ex pour être un
leader parce que c'est dans le challenge
personnel etc
mais c'est plus que les personnels parce
que il ya des milliers des personnes
dans le monde qui ont besoin de ce qu'on
développe ici
[Musique]
un plan du challenge du canada
administratif il ya les challenges d'égo
comme les certifications donc dont on a
besoin dans notre métier il ya l'accès
au financement
surtout dans le médical sur le web il ya
aussi la partie d'importation des
composants et le paiement en ligne a pas
de moyens de payer en vidant c'est ce
genre de problèmes qu'on trouve chacun
chaque jour dans notre aventure